a predator prequel a Knives Out Sequel
and a long glass more Avatar 2022 is
stacked with excellent upcoming movies
but which ones are a must watch keep
your eyes here for the best of the best
it's a very good time for high concept
action movies featuring major Stars
bullet train the next film from John
Wick and atomic blonde Alum David Leach
is another showcase for that kind of
filmmaking boasting a killer story hook
a stacked cast and what promises to be
some of the best action you'll see on
the big screen in the coming years the
film follows a group of Assassins who
all happen to be taking a trip on the
same Japanese bullet train as a journey
goes on they find that their respective
assignments have some unexpected
connections and the resulting clashes
will present a great opportunity for
some fun Close Quarter fight scenes dude
I don't even know you the cast has led
by none other than Brad Pitt who used to
employ leech as a stunts double back in
the fight club days but but spit is far
from the only major star involved in the
production bullet train has an
impressive cast that also includes
Sandra Bullock Michael Shannon Lady Gaga
and more the film launched production
during the pandemic rap shooting in the
spring of 2021 and will arrive August
5th 2022.
we've seen the Predator fight Special
Operations troops in the jungles and in
the cities we've seen it invade Los
Angeles and we've even seen it fight the
xenomorph twice we know the Predator
will endure at this point it's always
just a question of where we'll see it
next which probably meant a prequel film
was always inevitable now that prequel
is finally on its way in November 2021
20th century Studios Finally Revealed
that 10 Cloverfield Lane director Dan
trachtenberg's Long developing Predator
project was indeed a prequel and they
finally gave it a title Pray set many
years before the original film Frey will
follow what happens during the
Predator's apparent first trip to Earth
when the creature runs into a Comanche
woman who's trained to be a warrior and
will take on the alien Hunter on behalf
of her people the stripped-down approach
to the classic Sci-fi action franchise
will hit Hulu on August 5th 2022
almost immediately after Knives Out
became a major mystery hit over the 2019
holiday season writer director Ryan
Johnson began talking about potential
plans for a sequel those plans took
shape in the spring of 2021 when Netflix
signed on to a deal worth hundreds of
millions of dollars that was said
Johnson and Company up for two knives
out sequel films at the streaming giant
with the backing of Netflix and a lot of
Goodwill builds up from the first film
Johnson set to work and began building a
predictably stacked cast my presence
will be ornamental while the first
Knives Out film boasted an impressive
roster of talent only Daniel Craig is
expected to return from the first film
reprising his role as private detective
Benoit Blanc to take on yet another
mystery the nature of that mystery
remains unclear although we know at
least some of the film has been shot in
Greece plus The Ensemble Johnson's
building to populate the new story is
arguably more impressive than the one
from the first film film in the first
half of 2021 their production added some
major Stars including Dave Batista
Edward Norton Janelle Monae and Kate
Hudson to its curse ahead of a
production start later in the year the
knives sequel titled Glass Onion and
knives out mystery doesn't have a firm
release date yet but when it finally
hits Netflix sometime during holiday
season 2022 it might just be the
All-Star mystery to end all other
All-Star Mysteries
when it comes to Stephen King everything
old is always eventually new again the
horror authors enjoying popularity has
produced a fresh adaptation boom in
recent years and the latest project to
come out of that boom is a new take on
Salem's Lads his vampire novel that was
originally adapted as a mini-series in
1979 and then re-adapted for TV again in
2004. this time around the book which
follows a writer as he returns to his
hometown just as a vampire said sub shop
and begins to take over will get the
feature film treatment for writer and
director Gary Doberman whose previous
horror titles include the nun and
Annabelle comes home the new vision of
one of Stephen King's most terrifying
novels begins when Salem's Lots hits
theaters September 9 2022
after Halloween proved to be a massive
horror hit in the fall of 2018 Universal
Pictures and blumhouse Productions
announced that the sequel would form the
first part of a Trilogy focusing on the
ongoing battle between Michael Myers and
Laurie Strode after a pandemic delay of
approximately a year the second film
Halloween kills arrived in October of
2021 and established a frightening new
status quo for Michael and Laurie
setting the stage for Halloween ends to
arrive in the fall of 2022. at this
point we still don't know very much
about Halloween ends but director David
Gordon green has offered a couple of
tantalizing details for one thing the
film will Feature A Time jump to the
present day after both Halloween and
Halloween kills was set over the course
of Halloween night 2018. that means four
years will have passed since we last
caught up with Laurie and Michael and
all sorts of things could have happened
in the meantime plus green has made it
clear that as far as he's concerned the
story is over with the aptly named
Halloween ends which means we should
expect a fiery bloody conclusion
Halloween ends as in theaters October 14
2022. you know shallowing I guess
Everyone's entitled one good scare
for more than a decade now Dwayne The
Rock Johnson has been circling a
superhero movie while he's moved through
Blockbuster after Blockbuster cementing
his place has one of the biggest action
stars of his generation soon he'll
finally make his big screen super debut
after years of development and teasing
in the spring of 2022 after several
pieces of teaser footage Johnson Finally
Revealed the first trailer for the film
which will send to him as a Title
Character a kind of dark mirror of the
superhero we met in Shazam chosen to
wield the Shazam Powers ages before
Billy Batson Adam's Power was corrupted
when he received it but that doesn't
stop him from becoming a kind of
anti-hero in his own right introduced as
a villain in Comics Black Adam has
become a much more complex figure over
the years and it looks like Johnson's
film will Embrace that plus the trailer
showed off our first look at the big
screen debut of the heroes of the
Justice Society of America First
announced as major players in Black Adam
back in 2020 the film will feature Noah
centineo as Atom Smasher Aldous Hodge as
Hawkman quintessa Swindell as cyclone
and Pierce Brosnan as Dr Fate Black Adam
hits theaters on October 21st 2022.
a sequel to Black Panther has been
something Marvel Studios has been eager
about ever since the first film rocketed
to massive commercial and critical
success in 2018. in 2020 everything
surrounding that particular sequel
changed when it starred Chadwick Boseman
died at the age of just 43. that left a
lot of lingering questions and in
December of 2020 Marvel Studios finally
started to answer some of them drawing a
Disney investor Day presentation Kevin
feige announced that black panther 2
would indeed still be moving forward
under the leadership of director Ryan
coogler but we shouldn't expect another
ragda to embody king kachala of wakanda
instead we should prepare for a film
thus according to feige or Anna
Bozeman's memory and continue to explore
the world of wakanda thus especially
true now that we know the sequel will be
titled black panther wakanda forever
however it takes shape wakanda forever
is now set to hit theaters November 11
2022.
it's been more than a decade since James
Cameron released Avatar a massive sci-fi
spectacle that eventually became the
highest grossing film in history up to
that point back when the first film was
released we were supposed to get a
sequel within a few years then Cameron
pushed the development back in order to
advance filmmaking technology then it
was pushed back again and again and
again now at last an avatar sequel is
finally officially on the way titled
Avatar the way of water the film will
reunite original cast members Sam
Worthington Zoe Saldana it's a girly
Weaver and others for a massive new
Adventure on the alien planet Pandora
showing us parts of that world we've
never seen before are you serious yeah
as the title suggests we'll see much
more of the planet's oceans this time
around picking up on Jake and the tiri's
adventures years after the first film
when they've had a child and set up a
new life together but that new life
means new challenges including the
persistent threat better human
intervention on Pandora and internal
conflicts among the navi people Avatar
the way of water will finally hit
theater's December 16 2022.
in late 2018 and early 2019 Warner
Brothers did a lot of work to inject
some fun into its DC Comics extended
universe that effort began with Aquaman
which was a massive box office hit over
the 2018 holiday season and then
continued with Shazam which arrived in
early 2019 and attained a claim in its
own right it's never Rose for the box
office Heights of Aquaman but the film's
364 million dollar worldwide box office
Hall was solid for a film of its size it
was also apparently enough to green
light a sequel Warner Brothers announced
in late 2019 that a Shazam sequel was on
the way Zachary Levi is set to return to
the title role in the film with writer
Henry Gayden and director David F
Sandberg also set to return behind the
camera in 2020 the title was revealed to
be Shazam Fury of the Gods there's no
word yet on exactly what the plot will
be but the original film set up plenty
of opportunities for new foes including
the potential inclusion of Black Adam
after his own film drops but whether or
not he appears we know that Helen Mirren
and Lucy Liu will be showing up as
villains playing Daughters of the god
Atlas Fury of the Gods is currently
expected to arrive on December 21st
2022.
the folks at Warner Brothers have been
working to put a bad girl film together
for several years but it already started
to come together in 2021 when the film
founded star with in the Heights
breakouts Leslie Grace with Grace in
front of the camera Birds of Prey writer
Christina Hudson taking on the script
and the directors of bad boys for Life
helming the film The bad girl was often
running as a high profile feature film
project for the HBO Max streaming
service hey even the Batmobile don't
hold the road like this and once Grace
joined the cast things started to get
interesting rather quickly after the
film found the right actress to play
Gotham City resident turned vigilante
Barbara Gordon Batgirl landed JK Simmons
who will reprise his Justice League role
as Barbara's father commissioner Jim
Gordon then it was revealed that Michael
Keaton who's already set to return as
Bruce Wayne in the flash will once again
play Batman for Batgirl things got even
more interesting when Doom Patrol star
Brendan Fraser joined the cast as a DC
villain Firefly and Ivory three Aquino
stepped up to play a close friend of
Barbara Gordons who will be the first
trans character in a major superhero
film bad girl will arrive with some
serious star power on HBO Max at some
points in 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]